we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
pretty straightforward question and and
I have a pretty straightforward answer
from one of our voicemail callers take a
listen uh hello David big fan of the
show if you remember me I was in the
forum on nine areas of living all
northwest ohio rural communities anyway
my question was how much stupidity hang
or just blatant disregard for the truth
can republicans take a lot a my opinion
this question going to come down to how
well jumped in vs the public and i think
you could do that rather well but I just
I I don't I was around with many
Republicans I don't understand how they
can believe everything even brainwashed
and I just had to look at so so so
you're there's actually there's a lot of
things that are different that are going
on you have a contingent of people who
support from because they they are
cognitively limited that they're sort of
they're ignorant they're ignorant to
what's going on and they lack critical
thinking skills so they just fall for
stuff that's one component number two
there are people on the right who are
going to vote for Trump's reelection
merely to own the libs as they like to
say they refused to consider voting for
a Democrat despite the fact that Hillary
Clinton and Joe Biden have been very
centrist Democrats in in a lot of ways
and on principle in order to you know
attack or win against liberals they just
are going to vote for Donald Trump's
reelection that's another contingent
you've got a third contingent that is
people that recognize the dishonesty and
the lies but they see recognizing this
by voting for someone else as kind of
like admitting that they failed that
they got tricked in 2016 so there's like
a cognitive dissonance that's going on
where a lot of voters can't abandon
Trump because of what it would say about
them right and and so that's another
component and then there is another
contingent that actually benefits from
Trump's policy they're able to you know
run businesses extra profitably as the
regulatory apparatus
the United States looks away under Trump
or whatever right they have some
personal stake and they say the hell to
hell with everybody else so there's not
one answer and there is stupidity there
is tolerance of lies but there's a lot
more to it than just that but a very
very good question and well said I hope
that you will join the second David
Pakman show chess tournament it's going
to be Tuesday June 18th at 8:00 p.m.
Eastern Time it's open to everybody all
skill levels it'll be on LI chess org
that's li chess org
you can register now and then I'll be
streaming my participation in the chess
tournament we had 500 players in the
first one I hope we do better than that
this time around we also have a great
bonus show coming up for you today we
will talk about the burning of a police
precinct and the degree of approval
among the American public for it I'll
preview for you that it's quite low
number two the program cops has been
cancelled in the wake of what is going
on with George Floyd and number three
the dictionary merriam-webster will be
updating its definition of racism in
light of what is going on all of these
stories and more on today's bonus show
two ways to access it become a member at
join pakman.com or become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I'll
see you then